good afternoon everyone my name is David
Ellwood and I'm here and we're here at
the John F Kennedy jr. forum at the
Kennedy School welcome we're very very
pleased to have you all here this is
actually just about my favorite event
every year and the reason is we are here
to celebrate first the the two people
who did remarkable things in founding
the Kennedy School
Tom shelling and Richard Neustadt but
we're especially here to try and
celebrate a set of values which they
epitomized and that we hope at our best
the Kennedy School epitomizes and the
way we choose to do that is to find
others who epitomize those very same
values and that we can point to and
admire and indeed the only rule of the
new stat and showing Awards is we can't
select among ourselves which seems
appropriate at least some modesty
associative I cannot imagine a more
ideal combination of recipients this
year and I want to turn to energy and
talk about them in a moment but first I
want to mention the fact that the new
Staten shelling Awards came about
shortly after I became Dean thanks to
the generosity of one man and that's
David Rubenstein who's sitting right
over there hiding in the corner as is
his wad and
he's truly a remarkable man
a remarkable philanthropist and he's
been a remarkable gift to this school
I'd also like to acknowledge a couple of
other folks in the audience today
first of all with us we have Vartan
Gregorian who stanton who's sitting
right over here he is the he is the
president of the Carnegie Corporation of
New York he's former president of brown
many other remarkable things but his
most important achievement in the entire
world is that since its beginning he has
been the head of the selection committee
of the new stat and Schelling award the
other members of this selection
committee are Donna shillelagh nan
Keohane Glenn Hubbard and Paul Volcker
so thank you very much for our time in
addition we have Beth new staff who is
the daughter of mr. Neustadt right here
please
Beth is now quite around Harvard and of
course dick Neustadt was this remarkable
man who brought a set of experiences and
connections to the world but also cared
very very deeply about and helped found
this institution his he was if you were
president and you were transitioning if
you didn't have dick Neustadt centrally
involved in your transition we knew
ahead of time your presidency would fail
so no one did it so as actually we
couldn't really test this for sure but
he was part of every very everyone and
he was really such a thoughtful man who
understood so much about government and
I'm very happy to report that Tom
Schelling and his wife Alice are here
tom is right here
tom is simply a nobel prize winner he's
often credited as being the founder of
game theory he represents a group of
academics that have taken the very best
of theory and also made them relevant
and understandable on areas in Tom's
case as diverse as why is there such a
traffic jam on the way to the Cape as it
turns out there's a mattress that fell
off somebody's truck and we're all
waiting and taking a look and as once
since we've waited so long of course
we're all gonna look at that mattress
thereby delaying everyone behind us -
how do you prevent the spread of nuclear
weapons and so he was another one of the
very great minds that helped found this
institution as we're thrilled to have
you here Tom and to have this award in
your honor I want to now talk about the
new stat award and the new stat award is
given to someone whose work is
noteworthy for the practical application
of powerful ideas involving policy and
practice this is the case of
practitioners or people who have spent
considerable time as policymakers are
working closely with them the body work
should be driven by intellectual or
scholarly ideas as well as a strong set
of values and it should may represent an
outstanding contribution to society
among previous award winners have been
bill Brayton Alice Rivlin Paul Volcker
Muhammad Yunus senators Sam Nunn and
Richard Lugar this year's news this this
year's Neustadt Award winner is Mary
Robinson Mary is a leader with a Clarion
voice and a tough spine whose strengths
drawn from a keen eye for justice an
early example she made headlines as a
radical in 1969 as one of the University
of Dublin's three members in the Irish
Senate what she said was so outrageous
that she was denounced from the pulpit a
ballina Cathedral here are the things
she found troubling and that she
all for the area for change on she said
women should be allowed to serve on
juries she said we should date that
Ireland should eliminate the requirement
that women resign from the civil service
as soon as they get married and she and
this was the biggest outrage called for
the legal right to the availability of
contraception she has demonstrated her
passion for public service her
commitment to improving the human
condition globally and her ability to
skillfully use leadership positions
across sectors to advance these values
across a powerful and colorful lifetime
she is born of a family in Ireland that
was itself a historical mix of rebels
against and servants of the crown and
both her parents were physicians in
indeed she has creditor parents with
instilling her the idea as a female she
had just the same potential in the same
right an opportunity to be as
accomplished in the world as her four
brothers idea that was not entirely
common at that time in Western Ireland
or in most of the world the world was
her parents a great death because she
has given generously of her mind and her
values and her he has made a great
impact she studied law attorney to
college dublin king's in in ireland and
she spent a year here in cambridge at
harvard law school which she described
as a miserable terrible winter now I
have to just say one thing as much as I
admire Mary Robinson you ain't seen
nothing this winter was so nevermind
okay we got seven feet and 300 K so we
are very lucky that she was willing to
come back unfortunately spring his
return so all is all as well in her 20
she was called to the inner bars Senior
Council and appointed read professor of
law in credit ecology and her early
political career included election of
Dublin City Council as well as the four
mentioned I her Senate she's also worked
as a legal adviser on the campaign for
homosexual law reform after a tough
campaign Robinson became the first
Labour Party candidate the first woman
and the first first non áfreeá foil
free or not free HANA foil candidate in
the history of the contested
presidential elections to win the Irish
presidency and she was inaugurated as
the seventh president in 1990 she was
remarkably popular as president she took
an elected non-executive office that
previously had a relatively mild
reputation and breathe new life in
energy as she viewed it as an
opportunity to contribute her moral
voice she brought the President to the
presidency legal knowledge deep
intellect and political experienced she
reached out to the Irish diaspora and
following an old Irish custom put a
symbolic light in her kitchen window
enough in her official residence which
became seen as the sign of Ireland
thinking about its sons and daughters
around the world she extended a hand of
friendship to Northern Ireland and
changed the face of Anglo Irish
relations when she became the first
serving president of to visit the UK and
meet the Queen Elizabeth the second at
Buckingham Palace despite occasionally
being at odds with the church as in 1969
she actually established a quite close
working relationship and this ability to
bridge differences would become a
cornerstone of her career she was the
first High Commissioner of human rights
to visit Tibet she presided over the
2001 World Conference against racism in
Durban north south south africa as
secretary-general deciding to be close
to the victims of human rights and give
voice to those groups she visited
Somalia and Rwanda she stepped down from
this post and became involved in
numerous and geo activities co-founding
the council woman world leaders and
serving as the honorary president of
Oxfam she was also part of a group
founded by Desmond Nelson Mandela and
Desmond Tutu and Rossum account Mike
Mikkel known as the elders that seek to
bring wisdom leadership and integrity to
bear on the world's toughest problems
she is the 24th and first female
Chancellor of the University of Dublin
she has received numerous honorary
degrees and awards including the 2009
presidential medal of freedom from
President Barack Obama and now she
served as the UN Secretary General
special envoy to the Great Lakes region
in Africa
from 2013 2014 and now she's taken up
the post as special envoy for climate
change she heads the Mary Robinson
foundation climate justice a center for
the education of an advocacy of
sustainable and people centered
development in the poorest countries
perhaps her leadership can be best
summarized by quoting from the jury when
she was awarded the social science
principle do you a story us prize in
2006 one they commended her for a quote
offering her nonconformist brave and
far-reaching voice to those who cannot
speak for themselves or can barely be
heard
ladies and gentlemen Mary Robinson Mary
please come on up and we'll hand you
this and Beth if you'd be willing to
come forward please
and there's an 11th and we're good to go
just by way of rec those of you that
come before the news dad in showing
awards we've often had it in the evening
we have a different evening event
tonight but the what we're going to do
this time is after I've introduced each
of our awardees we're gonna take away
the podium and then have a discussion
about what's happening it was going on
in life so let me now talk about the
Schelling award Schelling award is given
to someone whose ideas have had a
powerful scholarly influence and also a
major identifiable impact on public
policy think in this case of scholars
who have spent a significant portion of
their time in academia though this is
not a requirement past recipients
include a March SN Esther Duflo dr.
Harold Varmus howard raiffa and Sarah
McClanahan and this year I'm delighted
to present our word to build Nordhaus
now there are two ways to grasp the
basis and scope of Bill nor houses work
the first is obvious in some ways a
usual one start with an early life and
indeed the New York Times did a piece on
Bill actually building his brother about
a year ago and they labeled Nordhaus a
quote Yale economist by the way I think
when they called him a Yale economist
both of those were compliments a Yale
economist who is seen as a leading
contender for the Nobel Prize came up
with the idea of a carbon tax and
effective in fact effectively invented
the economics of climate change but to
get there they said that growing up in
New York in New Mexico in the 1950s with
his brother Bob and their father are
specialists in energy and Native
American law New York Times said they
quote grew up steeped in the beauty of
the landscape the economics of energy
and the power of science they skied fly
fished explored the family's 50,000 acre
sheep ranch watch oil towns go boom and
bust and talked about talked of the
nuclear weapons on the road to Los
Alamos but there's another wait I kind
of understand and get a sense of Bill
Nordhaus one of the favorite article
that he's written or as a part of a book
really describes the history of lighting
throughout history starting with the
domestic use of fire and ending with
electricity and the like now he really
has written a terrifically interesting
article that goes through period by
period exactly when the big events
happened and when this or that and we
know we first did fire and then we had a
way of creating fire and moving two gas
lights and kerosene and so forth
ultimately going through the electrical
right era and so forth
now his interest was not strictly in
lighting though it is actually quite
fascinating
he wanted to use it to make a point
about how we measure price changes and
national output suppose for example that
everyone is using gas lighting as they
did in 1883 and some fellow like edison
comes along and creates electric
lighting okay here's the question what
just happened to the consumer price
index now I know not everyone that would
be their first question but it turns out
to be an unbelievably important question
because the consumer price index
determines a great deal on everything
from what we're gonna do in social
security increases to deciding the
wealth of nations and of course at the
very moment that gets invented nothing
happens because Edison no fool he priced
electrical lighting to be just about the
same price as gas lighting to make as
most money is to make money but over
time quite quickly the cost of grass gas
kind of kept going up cost of
electricity went down and of course the
technology evolved in and lighting and
so if you measured the price index by
saying well how much would it cost to
run a gas light today the answer is
quite high but nobody's using them and
how do you make those adjustments and
alike and for economists that's a great
and interesting set of issues technology
confuses us a great deal in trying to
think about how prices of the past
should be thought about in the future
when the world is so different and this
was a brilliant way to understand and
think about these things and this is the
sort of things that building arthouse
does
he what he does is he takes he does his
level-headed best to bring together the
most theoretical and empirical insights
to find answers to interesting questions
if it turns out that polluters are
pollutants are imposing costs on those
on all of us but those producing the
pollutants are paying not are not paying
for it well set a price of the
pollutants well that's kind of standard
economics though he made it standard
economics but at what price
particularly on climate if you think
about where it's gonna go into the
future it's the whole world how we think
about what price for climate well so
then you have to design the dynamic
integrated climate economy model dice it
quote integrates an end to end fashion
and in an in fashion the economics
carbon cycle climate science and impacts
of a highly aggregated model that allows
weighing the costs and benefits of
taking steps to slow greenhouse warming
in other words it can tell you what the
price should be at every different point
and what implications it might have
going forward
and he asked next he's been this year
the president of American Economic
Association always it was just recently
and his the interesting he decided very
off the president he can have American
Economic Association always gives a big
talk at the meetings these talks are
often big global you know reflections on
what's happened or whatever else but
Bill Maher has has always been looking
towards the future and so he instead
said okay here's the deal we want to do
something about climate change and we
have got the biggest free-rider problem
there is every country would like all
the other countries to take care of
climate change and not them and after
all most countries not the US and China
but most countries actually aren't a
very big part of the problem but
collectively they are the problem so he
came up with the notion of clubs and he
said well the club of Nations that
decide they want to do something
actually could decide to impose tariffs
and other kinds of things on the nations
that weren't willing to do something
thereby changing the incentives and the
like no doubt I've gotten is wrong but
our guest can correct us in a minute
the point is this is a man who is
constantly trying to say how do I use
ideas and theory and evidence to change
things no surprise that he was the first
chair of the Advisory Committee of the
Bureau of Economic Analysis to think
about federal statistics he's been on
the Faculty of Yale since 67 the full
professor of economics in 73 and also a
professor at Yale School of Forestry
environmental studies from 90 set from
1977 to 79 he was a member of the
President's Council of Economic Advisers
from 1986 to 1988 he served as Provost
as Yale I did note here this was just
two years this is a wise man and in 2004
he was awarded the prize of
Distinguished Fellow by the American
Economic Association before being
elected president merican and Kenai
Association to serve 2014 and 15 he will
be chair of the Boston Federal Reserve
Bank also from 2014-15 he's on all kinds
of awards he's author of numerous books
and regulate of things like growth and
welfare is growth obsolete the efficient
use of net energy resources managing the
global Commons warming the world and
drumroll please
he was the joint author of Paul
Samuelson's classic textbook economics
which exposed several generations
including a large fraction of the people
in this room to the magic and terrors of
economics his most recent book on
climate change is called the climate
casino his career opinion bodies the
innovation leadership and public service
across sectors that we aspire to his
faculty members and strive to inspire in
our students perhaps the American
Economic Association put it best when in
2004 they selected him as a
distinguished fellow where they said
throughout his career William Nordhaus
has displayed a knack for asking large
questions and addressing them was simple
but creative insights it sounds like a
whole lot sounds a whole lot like Tom
shelling to me and so it's very fitting
that we give this year showing award to
build our house you know
thank you could you come up
all right so as I said before we're
about to remove the podium here put up a
couple of chairs giving us just two
minutes and we will come begin a
conversation so I think we are going to
do this
Marybel could you please come and join
me please all right we're gonna carry on
a conversation here for a bit and then
there would there'll be a chance for you
to ask questions of either of our
panelists here so let me ask actually
both of you to start with a kind of
basic question what motivates you what
makes you focus on the things you care
about where does that all come from very
well I think the motivation has changed
a little bit as time went on it's for me
something to do with fairness justice I
mean I had a very early need to care
about human rights and equality because
I was wedged between four brothers two
older than me and two younger than me so
at the very beginning no no it's very
personal to I'm lucky enough to be an
Irish grandmother with five
grandchildren and they range in age
between 11 and 1 and I think a lot about
them and I think a lot about their
future and I think about the fact that
they'll be in their 40s in 2050 no no
sorry the youngest will only be 35 but
that's their sort of age midlife they
will share the world with 9 billion
people a climate constrained world maybe
a climate really disrupted world and I
often think back what they will think
about us particularly during this year
that gets me out of bed full of bigger
in the morning is there some incident or
thing that you look back on and that
you're most proud of maybe not the most
impactful whatever it's something you
sort of that that's really something
that that was important to me in a funny
way I think I've learned that you can do
a lot as an individual but if you can
strengthen an institution that's even
more sustainable so to be able to flesh
out the presidency in Ireland and make
it much closer to people and more
relevant
a lot of what was going on in Ireland
and then taking the office of High
Commissioner for Human Rights which was
a very beleaguered underfunded poor
office in the back end of the Paladin
accion when I started and try to
strengthen it and try to get funding and
try to get the administration better and
all the knots um both things that are
tough and boring I think but but just at
the end of my five years to see an
office that actually was beginning to
give leadership given rights for the UN
I know that that can then go on I think
they're the things that if I'm looking
back I feel doing yeah why'd you bill I
quoted the New York Times you're back
off what where do you get your drive
what makes you focus on what you do
well the sheep ranch was not as large as
they said they just were York Times I my
person is you can trust everything is
being part of coming out of the New
Mexico experience but I'll talk more
about my professional experience is
being part of this institution of
universities and I think of it as these
institutions are after all very old
almost among the oldest institutions in
the world human institutions and I in
there they are like a very large family
so I have as a student and being a
student of people who are my teachers
and meeting people like Tom shelling
relatively early in my career having
students that I worked with having
colleagues so that was actually very
formative in the sense that you're
getting ideas you're getting tools if
you like from the people you work with
from your teachers your colleagues your
students but then at every point you're
looking outside and asking
he described what are the issues today
that these tools could apply to so and
very early on on issues of technology
and you mentioned lighting which was an
application of that and then economic
growth and then later on environmental
issues and climate change so I would say
the way this is there's more stuff
there's more reflection here than is
then actually happens but is to take the
tools that I learned and I feel
comfortable with and use them to address
some of the key issues outside my study
so to speak and I think that's that's
what I think we and the academic world
do both of their students and in our
writing is to take the tools of whatever
our discipline is and see what the how
they can shed light on social issues but
we and academia are often accused of
actually often focusing on very very
narrow topics or topics that are of only
interest to the discipline and so forth
you clearly have never done that you do
you think that's an unfair criticism or
how do you think about that you may not
have read everything so you don't know
all the little bitty things and also
what I would emphasize is how many how
many get ends there are four I think for
everybody but I but research
how many times you go down something and
it leads nowhere
I was thinking about this little maze we
have in children where you you go in and
then you follow it down and then you
come to a dead end and you got to work
your way back and go down another
another little path I think there's a
lot of that and so you've got to be
willing to when you get to the dead end
to say this was a dead end I wasted it
however much time but it's a dead end
either because it's I guess can make any
any progress with it or because so one
of my colleagues I'll just say one one
thing my colleagues said is the most
important when I Jim Tobin actually said
the most important decision a young
scholar can make is what to work on and
I think we need to step back and ask
ourselves that question all the time
there's something that you've written or
were part of and so forth it you were
most proud of or most engaged with well
there are a lot of things I think I I do
have a particular fondness for lighting
I've just so I'll just I'll just I'll
just tell one story so one day I I was
trying to figure out how a lightbulb
work this was back in the era of the
compact fluorescent and somebody said
they don't work in freezing weather so I
decided I had better figure out if they
work so I went on and bought one and put
it in the freezer and my wife Barbara
who was here came home she's used to my
peculiarities
she opened the freezer and said I think
have you gone out of your mind
but then I explained it and so we raced
him with it with the light bulb which
had been at zero for several hours put
it in the light
and it worked but I think I have a
particular fondness for that because it
did involve trying to track down all
these weird people like the babylonian
period
i'll just say what nothing so we turn
this says something about academic life
it turns out we had a PhD student at
Yale who was just written a dissertation
on wages and prices in Babylonia and
where in the world where in the world
could you just walk across town and meet
meet such a person and that actually was
that was emblematic of what life
researcher my first question was how in
the world could you figure out what
prices were like advanced you were very
early to a set of issues around climate
change you and Tom were talking upstairs
earlier about the fact that you were
together on some small group that was
convened by President Carter because
that then was it I Minister whatever of
Germany Brett was was Chancellor of
Germany was was troubled about carbon
dioxide emissions and Carter at no idea
what or why you already knew something
about that tell me a little bit about
your history with this issue well so I'd
been working on economic growth and
technology in the as a as a graduate
student the 1960s and actually that was
it turns out that was too hard so I
basically gave it up it was just to
think about the economics of
technological change
I'm not sure if Mike shears here but he
and I worked on that about the same time
and so but then I turned to thinking
about other issues and with respect to
economic growth and particularly
constraints on growth you mentioned
earlier and what were the different
constraints and look
energy and it was clear at that point
that say in 1970 that climate change was
a potential constraint but there was
there was no linkage between the science
at that time and the physical science I
should say and the social science so the
way I got started I just was just one of
those lucky accidents I happened to be
spending a year in Vienna at the
International Institute founded by none
other than howard raiffa and howard was
director at that time it was first
director and I shared an office with a
climatologist and he asked what I was
doing and I asked what he's doing and
and we became interested he became into
some economics and I became interested
in climatology and it became clear at
that point that you could actually link
them up that was the first time but I'd
say I think it was clear by the nineteen
by 1900 by the late 1950s and surely by
1970 70s that this was going to be a
very big issue but as you say it was we
did with energy systems with Mary I'm
really quite humbled because when I was
serving as UN High Commissioner for
Human Rights I never had any sense of
climate change as being an issue that
might affect human rights which is what
I'm really concerned about now I never
made any significant speech I knew there
was a part of the UN the UN Framework
for climate change which was working on
this and having various conferences and
it was only after that in 2002 I came to
New York and formed a small NGO to work
on economic and social rights and we had
colleagues in Aspen in Washington
working on right to help and colleagues
in Geneva working on corporate
responsibility and I was working on
women peace and security and other
issues and we were focused on African
and I was traveling a lot because if
you're very small you have to partner
with the UN with other organizations I
was also honorary president of Oxfam as
you mentioned and Oxfam was inviting me
to be here and there and as I went to
various countries I kept hearing this
sentence that began over things are so
much worse and it was all about changes
in the climate changes in the weather
unpredictable events and it was all over
I mean I went to Liberia because we had
a whole programme there I knew Ellen
Johnson Sirleaf I would have breakfast
with her in the morning and she'd
explained to me that when she was
growing up the two rainy seasons in
Liberia were predictable to a few days
yeah at the different times of the year
now she didn't know when the rainy
season would come for how long it would
be and when this would you know and she
said I can't Minh my roads it's very
hard to plan and that was at one level
and then I was meeting people like
Constance of Keller's who became a
friend through Oxfam who growing up in
her village in northern Uganda said you
know we were poor but we had enough to
eat
and when you went to Seoul when he went
to harvest but as of about the year 2000
on the village suffered long periods of
drought and then flash flooding that
destroyed the school and then more
droughts and more flash flooding and she
said we thought that God was punishing
us and then we learned it wasn't God it
was the lives of rich people and I
thought that was a very significant kind
of sense it was the fossil fuel of the
developed parts the God that were
impacting on her village which was not
responsible and I heard it in the court
Somalia the Horn of Africa I had been in
Somalia as president in 1992 I was
invited by the Irish aid agencies to
return to Somalia in 2011 because there
was a famine there again in 1992 I had
no sense of any climate dimension to be
honest it was about warring warlords and
I spoke to both the warlords and tried
fact my husband accused me of poking one
of them in the tummy which I don't think
I did do but I may wagged a finger at
him anyway and do you think it's
inconceivable
I don't admit to it but in 2011 the
background research that I got was at
the Horn of Africa it had the eight
hottest years in succession and you
could just tell you could see the
devastating impact and that this is
going to get worse and I really became
aware that this was one of the most
serious human rights issues because it
was undermining development undermining
poor livelihoods undermining health
driving people out of their places where
they were living because of flooding
because of severe drought and that was
happening to a huge number of people
around the world but there were people
who didn't have a voice at the table and
so at the end of our my time working
with realizing rights I was already
talking about climate change I'd been to
Copenhagen and in Cancun we formed a
troika of women leaders on climate
because of the gender dimensions and
we've actually got gender more securely
gender balance into the climate
negotiations themselves because if you
undermine livelihoods and food security
it's women who pick up the pieces and
women of course are the large number of
farmers in in the developing world and I
then came to the energy side and I'm
fascinated that your interest in
lighting because we're now in an era are
we not where we're just about to see the
technology of solar make it a potential
contender to be the main energy source
what Tesla and others are doing in
battery storage not just in cars now but
in homes that are I mean this could be
what we need to move rapidly to
renewable energy wind and solar
particularly solar and thankfully the
Sun shines in the most trouble spots so
that can be a real source I would like
to see solar and wind that have become
like the mobile phone for developing
countries that they leapfrog into the
clean energy and don't have to use the
dirty energy that we've used don't have
to use fossil fuel energy but can can
move in that direction so I'd love to
hear whether you feel that there's
another book in solar lighting that
could be part of the climate solution
yeah well I think I think it can be part
of it but my own sense is that given the
economic forces particularly in the
densely populated countries developing
countries becoming middle-income company
countries becoming high-income countries
it's gonna be very difficult for the
renewable energy sources to displace the
fossil fuels if you take just take China
and India as two examples of countries
where there's a long way before any of
the renewables will push out
particularly coal so I think that's now
I said that hesitantly because we have
really underestimated the progress and
the cost declines particularly in solar
but actually in both areas over the last
20 years but still that I think there's
there's probably just not enough there's
just not enough earth and enough wind
and not enough economic cost advantage
to displace fossil fuels at current
prices and maybe even with technologies
10 to 20 years down the road so that is
that is what lead me lead me and lead me
to think that we're actually not going
to get there without without carbon
pricing and a sufficiently high price so
you basically drive the fossil fuels
maybe not out of existence but you're
going to minimize their role and also
you'll find technologies that can clean
them either out of the atmosphere or
from the smokestacks or from the fuels
themselves but if you look at I'm afraid
if you look at trends you in something
called decarbonization which is how much
more efficient we are in producing a
global output
in terms of the co2 component then
there's been actually very little
progress over the last 20 years the rate
of decarbonisation is virtually constant
so we're doing better it is true but
we're not doing better fast enough and
we're gonna need to prod you're gonna
need to prod this I won't say animal
because someone will object to that but
prod this beast which is the economy
through pretty I think pretty powerful
economic incentives if we're going to
get the kind of goals that you envision
has your how big a price do we need to
put on carbon as your and as your
thinking evolved over time well yes to
the last question I mean we've learned
we've learned a tremendous amount I
don't know a tremendous amount but I
think we in this area I know Dale was
here Dale Jorgenson was here earlier
it's been a pioneer I've learned a great
deal from his work and others here but I
mean one of the things the couple of
things we've learned one is that we're
probably gonna need pretty high prices
to really decarbonize the economy
whether it's 25 50 or $100 a ton it'll
be enough really to drive to drive coal
use essentially to zero and to economize
greatly or at least without being
cleaned up and to economize greatly on
the other fossil fuels
I would so but we don't have we don't
have any clear answer because we really
don't this is something we haven't done
so we it's like asking somebody what
what's the response going to be to
particular medicine when we haven't done
any experiments and we have analog
experiments but we've actually never
done it at the kind of scale we we need
so I think there's a tremendous amount
of uncertainty but I think as best guess
everybody's best guess is we did a
pretty high price to do it and do either
of you think we've got the political
will or the capacity to get there to see
how much support there is now for carbon
pricing I mean it has come much more
into the central debate
at the UN last September during the
climate summit there was a meeting and
you know a whole range of business
leaders signed up company countries
signed up to the need for carbon pricing
the trouble is the Free Riders who don't
sign up them I know you have your idea
of of a club of countries that are
committed but I think what we're seeing
in a way is a new scenario for trying to
see where the world is going as we move
towards Paris this year I mean this is
such a big year for decision making
earlier with some students I was
comparing us with 1945 which I really do
1945 was the year when the world had
been suffering from two world wars a
Holocaust dropping of nuclear bombs in
Japan opening up of the Cold War and
people were kind of driven by that sense
of never again never again and what did
we get we got the charter of the United
Nations we got the Bretton Woods
institutions the World Bank and the IMF
we got a Marshall Plan for Europe we got
a huge global solidarity and a couple
years later we got the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights and 2015 is
another year like that there hasn't been
quite one since and now we're there
again with the need for the world to
change direction on its development
literally a transformative behavioral
deep change if we're going to have a
safe world for future generations and it
begins with the financing for
development in Addis Ababa in July we
have to be innovative in financing we
have to have new commitment to financing
for developing countries because they
need the investment to have any chance
of really being able to go Khem
renewable energy and we then have to
have the sustainable development goals
which are for all countries in September
the 17 sustainable development goals and
the 13th goal is on climate change and
12 of the 17 goals in fact are relative
relevant to climate
and on oceans etc and consumption and so
on and they come into effect next
January and then we have the climate
agreement in December and the essential
point about the climate agreement is to
give integrity to the sustainable
development goals by putting us on a
pathway to stay below what what the
governments of the world have said is a
safe limit which is to stay below two
degrees Celsius of warming above
pre-industrial standards and the world
has agreed that scientists worry that it
may not be there may actually be a
worrying standard that in fact at two
degrees the world could be very
disrupted by climate so we should be
trying to stay below two degrees and
certainly small island states would go
under if we go up to two degrees so we
should stay below the two degrees what
the French are saying about the climate
agreement is that there will be four
pillars to the agreement the first will
be that climate agreement where
hopefully 194 countries will agree to a
pathway to keep us below two degrees it
would probably quite a short agreement
it's a very important one the next
pillar is that every country has agreed
to do what is called an it's a very
clumsy phrase it's intended nationally
determined contributions of how it will
reduce emissions in 2020 2025 2030 2035
and so on and the difference is that
every country now says we all have to do
this some should do more because they
have a steric responsibility and there
is common but differentiated
responsibilities in the convention but
every country now is geared to we have
to do as much as we can because it's so
serious and so that is the band of
intended nationally determined
contributions we have about 40-something
countries including the United States
that's already indicated what they're
going to do and it's not going to be
enough to keep us below two degrees so
we're going to have to some way of
reviewing and ratcheting up the ambition
so the agreement the nationally intended
intended contributions and then the
third pillar is the finance the climate
finance and the technology the
breakthroughs we hope for in the
technology and the fourth one is
all the activities that have been taking
place on carbon pricing on carbon smart
to find agriculture on what cities are
doing the Alliance of cities on the New
York Declaration and the Lima strategy
on forests all of the things that are on
what civil society is doing on what
communities are doing and they will all
be also part of the accounting in in in
Paris and to me that's a very sensible
way of going because Paris is just an
important step that has to put us on the
right course you know we're not going to
get there in Paris we have to be sure
that the agreement is such that we know
we're not on course and we have reviews
and a commitment to increase the
ambition to keep us on course so I very
much agree with you on carbon pricing
but yeah actually I'm more hopeful and
you seem to be that we can do it I've
heard people say we could do it by 2030
that we could have a renewable world if
we get the sufficient breakthrough is
particularly on solar battery retention
well this is this is very inspirational
I I don't want to rain rain on a parade
in Paris which is a beautiful city city
of lights it's not the city of lights
but that's a different story it reminds
me of a saying there was a senator from
Louisiana Russell long who was a chief
tax writer for the Senate and he was all
in favor of tax reform and what he would
say was don't tax you don't tax me tax
the fellow behind the tree and I I feel
that's where we are in you know of this
that we will all gather the log agree
that lofty goals but we will actually
not have national programs that are
consistent with these goals and more
important we're unlikely to have
programs that would implement them and
we can just start right here in the
United States we don't need to
point the finger we can start write it
right in this tree what they're doing
pretty well if you actually look at the
United States the United States actually
it's another example of a country that
is has not really even with all the
regulations we've had that the power
point regulations the car regulations
the regulations of houses and so on we
have not made very much progress I just
I just so I'll just come back to the
what I think the problem the problem of
the free writing and the reason I think
that Paris will basically stumble the
same way the earlier conferences have is
because they there's no mechanism to
induce countries to go beyond some
modest goals in terms of their actual
implementation I mean the u.s. is not
close to meeting any ambitious goals so
I I think again I I would like to think
it I would hope it but I think
economists aren't paid to hope they were
paid to calculate and to look at look at
not what people say but what they do and
outside of Europe basically no one is
doing anything and within Europe
European trading system is basically
falling apart because of another set of
issues so I I would I would like to be
able to agree with you that we're doing
something but I think unless we get to
the point where we have an agreement
that where there's some incentives for
countries to actually implement their
programs we're not going to I would come
back to your but I want to come back to
1945 which I remember a little bit as a
little I was just out of diapers but I
do remember there was so if you look at
the Bretton I want to go back to the
Bretton Woods agreements which were very
interesting agreements and
you know the Bretton Woods exchange rate
agreement lasted until 1971 so that's
that's pretty good the the actual
institutions have survived to this day
although the WTO was quite different
from what the original design was but
they had a completely different design
from a point of view of treaty design
and that was they were had a small
number of countries like to the United
States and Britain designing
institutions and they were designing
institutions that they thought countries
would won't eventually want to join and
when they would join would improve the
either the finance in the case of the
IMF or or trade in the case of what is
now the WTO so it's a completely
different design from this bottom up
what I call the bottom up treaties that
are the treaties of IPCC of the of the
IPCC and the organisations associated
with that so my own thought is what you
need is something actually quite like
the Bretton Woods treaties where you get
a small number of countries to think
what kind of treaty would be one that
not only would be when people would want
to join the way they want now to join
the WTO but would also be ones that
would eventually as they began to
tighten be able to attain maybe not a
two degree to go but something better
than the trajectory that were on now and
I think until we get to the point where
we're thinking of treaty design with
incentives for countries to join into
something that has costly domestic steps
to actually it's gonna be slightly
painful for countries to take these
steps and they're gonna have to take it
not because they want to take it for
their own national economic interests
but because part of it and not because
they're altruistic because companies
have limited altruism I live in a regard
for other countries welfare but because
as in the case of the WTO it's part of
the rules of the game in the WTO the
rules of the game are you
have to keep your tariffs low and if you
don't you'll have other countries put
tariffs on you so it has to be the rules
of the game that you have to do steep
emissions reductions and if you don't
there will be consequences the problem
with the current design is that we've
had such secure is there no consequences
if countries just go about their
business and do whatever they want so I
think that that's where I see a missing
ingredient in the pillars maybe the
French maybe it's asymmetric and not
French tat five pillars but you need a
fifth pillar in that which is something
that harnesses countries self-interest
to deep and steep emissions reductions
or else so we do have time for a few
questions there at microphone here here
of here and right here and so I'm hoping
some of you are curious enough to ask a
question now let me just explain this is
probably the last time in my life I get
to say this a good question at the
Kennedy School consists of three
elements first you identify yourself
second you keep the qubit relatively
short with one thought and third it
should end with a question mark
so with that my name is that Sharlee
Clements I'm with a car Center for Human
Rights policy my question this afternoon
is Professor Nordhaus in the fall of
2002 you published an economic study
that countered the Bush administration a
theory that the war in Iraq would be
self paying for by that the economic
revenues gained by the increase in oil
production would pay for the cost of the
war and it would cost us absolutely
nothing and of course that turned out to
be erroneous but I was curious what kind
of reaction you had to your study it was
a breath of fresh air at the time it
turned out to be very modest I think in
terms of the actual cost the worse as
Joseph Stiglitz showed later but if you
could talk about your response to that
would be very appreciative oh that was
actually
that was an interesting month that would
took about a month's work and so the
essence so this was done about five
months before the war started the world
began and it was it's a little bit like
lighting in the sense it was a pretty
offbeat field there was actually very
little work in defense economics as it
was called had declined in the economics
profession there was a there was
virtually nothing at that time being
written in the area I was a little
shocked actually and the person who
encouraged that was Caucasian he had
read an early draft and said well you
have a couple of inflammatory things you
should take this out but otherwise he
encouraged I got I got I'll just mention
two reactions I got one was from a
member of the Treasury who said to
somebody who told me he said Nordhaus is
crazy and I don't know what he meant by
that but I think he meant that he's he's
got this vivid imagination for all the
things that can go wrong and we in the
Treasury know they're not going to go
wrong and then I got a really I got the
sweetest letter I ever got from Ken
Galbraith who said I have two piles in
my office one for papers that are okay
and ones for papers that I read and I
think are important and yours goes in
that pile and that was a really nice
that was one of the nicest letters IRA
got so I think in retrospect it was the
kind of it was it was it turns out to be
very difficult I'll mention something
about the Stiglitz and colleague here
films is it bill bill moose who has done
I did a great study and one of the
things that was omitted and I just
overlooked was the injuries and the
cause
to the u.s. of the I thought she thought
about it but I didn't I didn't I was
thought about the fatalities but I
didn't really think about the injuries
it all had no conception about what they
would be the scale of them and how
costly not just to the federal budget
but as a society that would be but I
think that I look back if the reason I
think this has any enduring value if you
want to know what people thought before
going into the war you might want to
read it because it's really hard to
reconstruct the optimism and the
jingoism and the way people thought this
was just we're just gonna blow right
through and it's gonna pay for itself
it's and after this long series this
disaster and other disasters fiscal and
military really hard to remember how
optimistic we were in yes I'm Catherine
siccing the Ryan family professor of
human rights policy at the Kennedy
School and I have a question for Mary
Robinson that also goes back to that
same period as Charlie's question I
heard you speak very eloquently after
9/11 in at a time when you you called
the 9/11 bombings about that they could
be considered a crime against humanity
and you suggested a vision of using law
as a way to approach that crime against
humanity and I wonder if you could just
play out for us a possible
counterfactual that might not have
involved this very expensive war that
might have been effective about
confronting terrorism yes I remember
very well because my final year as UN
High Commissioner for Human Rights
started on 9/11 I just served for a year
until the year after and so when the
terrible attacks took place I came to
New York and went to Ground Zero med
family's myths and the FEMA
people who are working and others and
and and sat in my office to think what
does this mean for human right so we
were quite clear that these were crimes
against humanity when you have
aeroplanes full of gas and people aimed
at buildings to kill as many people as
possible there's no doubt this would
constitute a crime against humanity
under international law and immediately
after 9/11 there was that sense that the
world was with the United States and we
must remember that I mean every country
in the world was saying you know
expressing sympathy expressing empathy
outraged at what had happened and the
Security Council passed a resolution
that sort of brought us much further on
in addressing terrorism than we had been
and just by the sheer need to be
together on this and I think if there
had been a determination to go after the
perpetrators of crimes against humanity
which was in fact Osama bin Laden and
his and those were with him in
Afghanistan but we were already hearing
a very different way of addressing this
which was the war on terrorism and war
is a very kind of broad sweep way of
doing things where people swept up just
after 9/11 and and so on and it also
doesn't prioritize our balance and the
need to protect human rights and I felt
then and I feel still very strongly that
the way to counter the those who want to
undermine values is to uphold those
values yes you have to protect your
people yes you have to secure them you
have to take measures you can in fact
take emergency measures under
international human rights law but but
the focus should be on addressing what
the issues where the crime against
humanity and it would have been possible
to bring Osama bin Laden before an
international tribunal a tribunal could
be set up for that it would have been a
very different world I think and and
probably not have us now in the morass
of what we see in the wider Middle East
Arthur Applebaum I teach political
philosophy at the Kennedy School so I
have a question for for both of you so
you're both exquisitely sensitive to the
passage of time both the very very
distant future and the past Mary
Robinson you talk about your
grandchildren bill Nordhaus you talk
about Babylonia and the founding of the
University and of course you are
projecting the consequences both of you
of many many many many years into the
future of climate change but it turns
out that it's unclear how we're supposed
to think about that I mean I'm an
economist my fellow traveler and we
think we've solved the problem we've got
this thing called the discount rate
right but of course as you know the most
you know careful careful sophisticated
modeling economic modeling is gonna be
very very sensitive to very small
changes in the discount rate and I don't
mean simply building in adjustments for
inflation the opportunity cost but in
the pure time preference right and of
course Mary Robinson I don't think you
think about the pure time preference but
surely you have a sense of how far how
are we supposed to care about people a
hundred years from now so I'm asking not
as a technical matter of modeling but
rather just says as a normative matter
how are we supposed to care about people
who are gonna live 200 years from now
well curiously I'll start with the fact
that when my first grandchild was born
who's now the 11 year old and I did have
some kind of I can only describe it as a
kind of physical reaction to the joy of
his birth the pride in his birth he was
the first child of my daughter when I
was 2 and in in some strange way I
recalibrate her and I began to care
about a hundred years hence because that
was going to be his life I mean I'm
talking as a grandmother now and that
also links very much with how I think
about 2050 and what that world will be
like for the nine billion people who
have to find food and water and live
together and and have the energy they
can use and what kind of energy it'll be
and it you know so it's for me it's
extraordinarily real like you know I
really think about it in a very tangibly
real way because I relate to it and I
care about
I mean I I took part in the the March
last September in New York the big
climate March before the climate summers
and it was a great pleasure to be with
so many people I mean they predicted a
hundred thousand in fact 400,000 people
came out and we all wanted to be there
with everybody else and there were
banners about all kinds of things I was
with GRU Brundtland and it was a
pleasure to be with her as a fellow
elder and we had our elders banner and
we had a crowd around us who were you
know seeing us as elders on the march
and I saw another banner that I tried to
sort of move towards but we were wedged
in together because there were so many
of us you couldn't really move except
when the crowd moves slowly forward and
the banner that I wanted to go behind at
least for a little while was angry
grannies because I thought this is the
one that really speaks to me
you know and what I really think more
and more and it gets me out of bed in
the morning is we are facing an
existential threat it's the first time
we've had this kind of issue an
existential threat the World Bank has
written about what a four-degree world
would be like it's a report a couple
years ago called turned down the heat
and they extrapolated and it is
catastrophic and we are facing at least
a four degree world at the moment and
that's where the scientists tell us and
I was in the Potsdam Institute a couple
of weeks ago with my colleagues we work
closely with John Sheldon Huber he's one
of our advisors a very well-known
climate scientist and you know at a
certain point when John Sheldon who was
showing us all these graphs and I said
well just spell out and very plain
English to me
I'm a non-scientist I've come late to
climate but I now see it as a big human
rights issue
what does staying below two degrees
Celsius really mean in practical terms
and he says what it really means in
practical terms is getting to zero
carbon by 2050 globally zero carbon
means we have about a 60% chance of
staying below two degrees Celsius 60%
chance which is you know that good a
chance and I wonder what it will take
yes carbon pricing I would be all
forests because that's one economic
lever that would get us there but how
you know how can we be so
so strangely uncaring about our children
and grandchildren that we're not coming
together much more in a sense of global
solidarity because no no country can do
it on their own the United States can't
protect itself from the impacts of
climate change and nor can any other
part of the world it's it's like as if
we're in a Titanic to simplify things
we're heading for the rocks the rocks of
the kind of tipping points of climate
change and if we hit those tipping
points then it's not just those in
steerage it's the first class passengers
everybody will suffer and I think the
the current foreign minister of France
laun fabulous and has said a number of
times and I think he pretty well uses it
now in every speech he says he says we
are the first generation to understand
the dangers of climate change and the
last generation the time to do something
about it
now for me I I read actually and I meant
to bring it along with me because I was
going to blame you David among others
because you're a teacher Dean of the
thing that young people in the United
States don't regard climate change as
high on their agenda if that's true it's
incredibly serious because it should be
one of the highest things on young
people's agenda because it's their lives
and it's their futures and you know I
mean your fault that's a really
interesting question I think there's a
there's a kind of technical question
that you alluded to about what people
use in investments either public
investments or private investments but I
don't really want to go there because we
could we could I think that's actually
not the crucial issue I think one issue
is that many of our political
institutions behave as if they have very
high discount rates or short time
horizons
and the time that became very vivid to
me was when the u.s. almost defaulted on
its national debt because of a stalemate
in the Congress I don't actually know
whether we were that as close as as some
thought but it was close enough if
something had gone wrong and there had
been some kind of this game of chicken
some kind of stalemate that there could
have been some pretty terrible
consequences for the United States and
there was nothing nothing to justify it
other than political bargaining but to
think that a country would put its good
faith and credit on the line the country
with the strongest and most mature and
important financial system in the world
on the line is a kind of sense of the
political the high political discount
rate at the low short time horizon of
some of our institutions so I worry much
more about that than I do Yale's
discount rate or Harvard's discount rate
or the discount rate of individuals here
so but but I wanted just a slightly
different point so well then I ask the
question okay what what is it that is
important passing on to the next
generation I think the discount rate
issue doesn't really get at that either
and I think one of the things Mary's
alluded to is is the natural environment
but I think also what we I think the
physical capital and the tangible
capital and things like that are less
important than the institution's we pass
on the institutions of good governance
institutions like our our you know our
colleges and universities and our school
systems and so if I worry about any
specific thing that we're not passing on
in a responsible intergenerational way I
were less about I mean I don't like
potholes but I were less about potholes
and infrastructure
than I do about the quality of our
institutions and particularly our
political institutions and that's that's
and also our international institutions
quality of international institutions I
mean there there have been some there
there is some good news after all in
terms of the declining lethality you
have interstate conflicts that's really
good news
I mean if you look at what's happened to
deaths deaths in Wars four million
people that is way down and that's
that's good news now there are also
there always obviously risks there of
nuclear war but there are some good news
but we still I think I think the place I
would focus on the international
international institutions and to the
extent that its climate change some I
would just simply say I will take the
blame for the political institutions as
well we after all are the Kennedy School
but I'd rather turn in an oil which is
that this actually is an institution
that thinks it's our job to try and fix
those and with our hearts and our heads
in our hands I think this is an
unbelievably important moment and thank
you for demonstrating that those things
can be put to good use and to as I say
really symbolize the kind of values that
we we admire so thank you very much
please join me in thanking the other guy